wie ist jetzt gerade die situation am
großen stern an der siegessäule in
berlin auf seite heute vormittag sind
wieder einige tausend demonstranten an
der siegessäule am großen stern in
tiergarten versammelt es sind zum
großteil gegner der politik der
bundesregierung gegen die korona
verordnung und dazwischen natürlich auch
im gegner ist habe einen raise begriff
lager gesehen
es ist mittlerweile etwas aufgeheizte
stimmung weil diese demonstration gerade
zwischenzeit bittet die polizei
aufgelöst wurde
wir erinnern uns zu gut an die bilder
von gestern wo er zahlreiche
demonstranten dann auch weggetragen oder
festgesetzt werden
wie sieht es jetzt genau dort aus greift
die polizei jetzt weiter ein oder fährt
sie weiterhin die strategie der
deeskalation also erst mal beobachten
und ruhig bleiben
das kann man ganz klar so sagen es hat
heute morgen versuche gegeben erst
erfolgloser polizei zählte von der wiese
vor der voerder siegessäule zu entfernen
dann haben sie eine ganze zeit lang
angeguckt und dann später haben sie
diese zu entfernen
es haben heute nacht wurde durch als
auch demonstraten übernachtet und gerade
wie gesagt zwischenzeitig von die demo
aufgelöst das wurde einer der der rede
führer zwischenzeitlich von der polizei
mitgenommen und jetzt auch ein bisschen
unklar wie die situation aussieht wie es
weitergehen wird
es wird er geschätzt dass so ungefähr
bis zu 1000 menschen dort vor ort sind
hast du ein gefühl dafür was für
menschen da sind es ist ja sehr schwer
zu beschreiben der mix an demonstranten
nehmen wir auch gestern in der
hauptstadt hatten wer versammelt sich
denn jetzt dort am großen stern und weiß
fordern die menschen
es erinnert ein bisschen an die stimmung
gestern nachmittag
es sind zum überwiegenden teil
friedliche menschen die hier kommen
gegen die korona verordnung
demonstrieren gegen das masken verbot
demonstrieren das ist ein bisschen das
problem der veranstalter weist das auch
das querdenken das ist der veranstalter
auch gestern die kundgebungen
organisiert hatte die veranstalter
versuchen die leute zu sensibilisieren
abstand zu halten und in erster linie
geht es natürlich dagegen zu sagen wir
waren keine maske tragen wir wollen uns
nicht von der politik etwas vorschreiben
lassen
aber auf der anderen seite gibt es auch
genug leute die wie gestern ähnlich vor
der russischen botschaft fordern eine
neue verfassung
stichwort reisberger leute wie
tatsächlich der meinung sind dass die
brd aktuell keine verfassung hat gibt es
ja auch das ist nicht der überwiegende
teil muss man ehrlicherweise sagen
überwiegender teil sind friedliche
menschen die dänen die korona maßnahmen
genutzt werden wenn sie demonstrieren
gegen die kuchener maßnahmen dennoch
sehen wir im hintergrund bei dir auch
durchaus demonstranten die eine maske
tragen wird sich denn dort jetzt ein
abstände gehalten oder werden zumindest
masken getragen vielleicht kannst du uns
ein bisschen wie menschen zeigen die
sich ja auch interessiert um dich dort
fahren genau es gibt sicherlich einige
menschen die eine maske tragen ist es
nicht die mehrheit die mehrheit trägt
tatsächlich keine maske heute hier aber
noch einmal der veranstalter der
versucht so ein bisschen darauf
hinzuweisen dass zumindest abstände
eingehalten werden ansonsten wird die
demo aufgelöst das hat die polizei
gerade mehrmals gesagt
jan ist vielen herzlichen dank für deine
einschätzungen